if it's anything like pha this is going
to be fun
i tried
i don't know what vietnamese street food
is i'm definitely expecting a lot of
spice
i've never eaten vietnamese street food
before and i have it a lot but we've
both eaten food that's fallen on the
street
i grew up eating vietnamese food and
chinese food so i definitely had
some of these cheers buddy
god damn this isn't the fault of the
food
but there's cilantro in it and so it
tastes like garbage
the meat is so big in it i think i'm in
love not lipstick friendly
this spring oil i don't even want to
like keep eating because i just want to
have it forever
okay smells so good
i'm excited because shrimp your parents
would make it like fresh
and they'll bring out a batch and it's
like hot and then you'll finish it and
they'll bring another one and another
one and another one
is the fish sauce made of fish yes
okay um i
fish sauce though son this is dope this
is very very tasty
are you gonna eat that onion
there's pig three ways on this plate my
mom used to make this too like in a big
bowl
and literally i'll just eat it for meals
and meals it sounds like your whole life
growing up was your mom turning out food
and you're just eating it
it's like thanksgiving all the time like
you get so much
different kinds of foods everywhere all
the places do you realize
that combining things makes them better
i do know that
that's why i'm combining all this food
into my face i want it to be a little
firmer
oh no i love the softness i would drink
fish sauce
wouldn't you no my breath is gonna smell
like this for days
oh
the brown black stuff is chunky is it
beans
oh god the texture of the green stuff
is really weird i really like it when
the desserts are also an activity
because it's just fun for the kids it's
crunchy it's chewy it's like
gooey it would be really like awesome
and refreshing for a summer day
i love that it's like ice cream but not
too cold to give me a brain freeze
it brings me back home to like my family
and my mom and like
i i love it so much asian people always
do
you guys know what you're doing you do
food it's so good
food the fish sauce yeah i mean that was
cream of the crap i want to eat
vietnamese street food for the rest of
my life
we out we did it good job sorry